today's question comes from Stephanie in
Nevada where do collections fall and
baby step two do we pay them first or in
the order their balances like everything
else if you've got outstanding defaulted
bad debt set that aside you're not
paying on it anyway
and figure and finish your debt snowball
and baby step two that is your regular
active debts things your paying payments
on list your debts smallest to largest
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and work your way right
down that list now once all of your
active debts are gone then take all of
your defaulted in collections that
you're not paying payments on debt
inactive debt and list its smallest to
largest only we're not going to pay them
payments we're going to just pay them
off smallest to largest now if it is a
small debt under $300 you call them up
you get in writing by email or something
like that what the balance is not verbal
over the phone it's an old debt you
don't want to send them $275 from a
six-month ago bill and then then come
back and say we owe you owe is 1275
dollars because we added late charges
and they will do that kind of crap so
every time you have an old debt before
you pay it get in writing what it is now
if it's a small one just pay it so you
knock out the little mosquito debts the
$52 the whatever that right all the
little mosquitoes flying around your
head knock those out then when you get
to the larger ones then you call them up
when you've got a little bit of money
and you make them an offer and say you
owe them $3,000 they say you owe them
$3,000 you look it up and go my goodness
I was $1,000 on a credit card they sure
have added a lot of late charges and a
lot of gotcha fees a lot of collections
fees to that so I'm really gonna offer
him $1,000 on that three thousand
dollars in quotes balance but it was
originally a thousand bucks
I'm probably going to offer them about
what you originally owed or maybe even
less but pennies on the dollar 25 30
cents on the dollar in cash as an offer
do not give them any money unless you
get the agreement to the amount that you
want to pay in writing and you'll have
to work your way through that argue your
way through that it's not easy
never send collections people money if
you don't have the amount in writing
first you can tell they're lying if
their mouth is moving there are one or
two good people in the business and the
rest of them are scum they lie all the
time we work with them all the time
credit card collectors a hundred percent
of you that are credit card collectors
lie a hundred percent of you lie and if
you say you're not lying that was a lie
it's that simple
so that's how you're dealing with now
you owe money and you didn't pay your
money so we're you know we're not giving
you like a pass here we're not setting
you up to be the next pope or something
but the deal is you need to get your
bills paid but do not believe them oh
well you know little Joan I talked to
Joan on February the 3rd and Joan told
me to send two hundred ninety three
dollars and they'd be cleared well Joan
just lied if you don't have it in
writing it didn't happen that's what an
old lawyer friend of mine used to say if
it's not in writing it didn't happen so
in writing on a piece of paper on an
email print it off keep a copy of the
money order that you send them the
second thing is you do not give them
electronic access to your checking
account after you agree to a certain
amount they're going to want to draft
your account for that amount once again
have I mentioned that they lie they will
take more out than they have agreed to
try getting it back good luck with that
oh you told me it was gonna be two
hundred ninety three dollars you took
out twelve hundred bucks I can't pay my
house payment oh well we changed our
mind sue me this is the kind of crap
they say to people all the time no
electronic access to
checking account they will clean your
butt out do not trust them get it in
writing and then send them a check or
set up a prepaid debit card that has
just that amount on it only and draft
that and then cut that card in half and
do it again if you're gonna use a
checking account don't put any more
money in the account then the amount
that's agreed and do not use that for
the same account you pay your bills out
of because they will clean you out do
not have automatic draft from your
payroll put into an account that a
collector has access to that account
you're gonna get yourself in a mess we
run into it all the time
helping people work through these things
so doing all of that then you work your
debt snowball and work your way back
through the inactive accounts and you
clear them off by in writing settle it
in writing settle it in writing settle
it in writing settle it and then you're
clear in most of the time twenty-five
cents on the dollar ten cents on the
dollar of what they say you owe is gonna
sound more like about what you
originally owed or a little bit less
depending on who you're dealing with
what kind of debt it was and all that
kind of thing but they'll settle with
you if you offer them cash now I will
send you money this instant on this
debit card this prepaid debit card off
to the side or there's checking account
off to the side or I'll send you a
cashier's check overnight and pay the
FedEx charges but do not let them in
your account you'll get messed up and
messed over hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]